(keyboard clicking)
- I'm happy to introduce Ari Ne'eman.
I think many of you have
heard Ari speak before.
He's the President and Co-founder
of the Autistic Self, oh.
- Was, was.
- Was, he was, but he's gonna
tell you what he's doing now,
and he's here to talk to us about
quality in-home and
community-based services
to support successful community living.
Ari, thank you.
- Well, thank you so much.
It's an honor to be back here at
the Update in DD Conference.
I'm sure at some point
they'll have the timer
continue to move, but in the meantime,
I'll just keep track from my phone.
My name is Ari Ne'eman,
many of you know me
from some of my past roles.
From 2006-2016, I ran the
Autistic Self-Advocacy Network,
a National advocacy organization
run by, and for, autistic
people, speaking for ourselves.
From 2010-2015, I was
one of President Obama's
appointees to the National
Council on Disability.
I currently direct a
project called MySupport
which I'll talk a little bit about here
which focuses on giving
people with disabilities,
and families, more tools to find workers
that share their values.
I'm really pleased to have the opportunity
to talk with you on the topic
of home and community-based
service quality.
There has been a
tremendous amount of change
in our field, in the world
of developmental disability,
over the course of the last 10-20 years.
That change has largely
been for the purpose
of promoting more self-determined lives,
more quality of life,
more choice and control
in people's outcomes, but one of the
unfortunate challenges that we have
is that it's relatively rare
that we go to a service provider,
and we pick up their brochure,
and they say we are against
self-determination, choice and control,
and for coercion,
restraint, and you know,
generally speaking, if
you look at the marketing
in our field, from the service providers
to the health plans in some states,
to any number of other entities,
folks say they're for good things,
and they're against bad things.
The problem that we have is, historically,
we've had very few tools to evaluate
whether that is in any
reasonable sense, true.
In the context of quality measures,
there's a long history of states using
healthcare quality measures usually
to hold managed care plans accountable
for particular kinds of outcomes,
but most of the quality measures
that have been used historically
have focused on very traditional,
medical care outcomes.
They may evaluate the
degree to which folks
were in an emergency room
in the last 12 months,
or the prevalence of diabetes,
or the speed with which particular forms
of medical treatments are used
within a certain timeframe upon entering
an emergency room or a doctor's office,
but as we've started to
see more of an emphasis
on quality improvement in
long-term services and supports,
and in home and community-based services,
we've started to see
an emphasis on quality
around measuring outcomes in
the home and community-based
service world.
I recently completed, along with Steve Kay
from the University of
California San Francisco,
a two-year term of service on
the National Quality Forums work group
on home and community-based
services quality measures.
What I'm going to be doing here
is I'm going to be going through
a variety of quality measures
that states are using,
sometimes to evaluate the
performance of managed care plans,
within states that have adopted
managed care frameworks for their
disability and aging services,
sometimes to evaluate the performance
of individual service providers,
and sometimes to evaluate themselves,
and to really ask and challenge themselves
what we can do to improve
the quality of services
we may be administering at the State's
or Regional Center level.
So, with that old maxim of
"In God We Trust, Everyone
Else Please Bring Data",
let's jump right into it.
One of the first domains
that the NQF work group
on HCBS quality looked
at was service delivery
and effectiveness.
I want to highlight four quality measures
used in actual
state-managed care contracts
or quality improvement
systems that look to measure
quality in disability services.
The first, the number of
service hours delivered
minus the number of service hours approved
is used by the state of Delaware's
Managed Long-Term Services
and Support System.
The second, the percent of
people with disabilities
responding yes to: Do
the services you receive
meet your needs and goals?
is from the National
Core Indicators Project,
it's a quality improvement
system historically used
only for people with
developmental disabilities
and it recently expanded to the aging
and physical disability world.
The proportion of
Individualized Care Plans
with goals unmet comes from the New York
Managed Care System.
And the fourth, which
also relates to the number
of late/missed visits and talks
about the reasons for them
comes from Tennessee's system.
One of the things I
think is really important
to highlight here, and
we're gonna be seeing this
fairly consistently
across each of the domains
of quality measurement
that are being utilized
by states and by service
providers for different purposes,
is that these are very
different kinds of measures
and they have very different
strengths and flaws.
Generally speaking, states
will seek to incorporate
at least some measures that can be derived
specifically from utilization data,
so the number of service hours delivered
minus the number of
service hours approved,
and then compliment those
measures with measures
that are derived from survey data,
like the National Core
Indicator's Project.
NCI surveys large numbers
of people with disabilities,
family members and
providers for the purposes
of determining whether or not
someone has choice control,
autonomy and other dimensions
of quality in their life.
The reason why, usually,
in well-designed systems
states will cup a couple
data from quality measures
from utilization data with
quality measures from survey data
is that generally speaking,
it's possible to see
really significant flaws in both.
We all know that survey data
is often highly subjective.
People are often not aware
of the degree to which
other options may exist so
to talk to someone about
whether or not they feel they are included
in the community if all
they've ever been exposed to is
a group home and being
included in the community
to them means that somebody
takes them to the mall
once a week, is often not
the most useful metric
because there isn't
really any determination
that there's been an informed
process by which folks
are deriving their
answer to that question.
At the same time, data
that comes from just strict
analysis of the kinds of
services that people receive
is often at times misleading.
For example, if we look
at the Delaware statistic,
the number of service hours delivered
minus the number of
service hours approved,
one problem with looking at that statistic
as the sole measure of
quality is that a particular
health plan may be more likely to approve
more service hours than somebody needs
as a means of preparing
for crisis situations
in which a pre-authorization
requirement for adding
more service may
significantly delay access
to necessary support.
So if all we're looking at is the ratio
of services delivered as
compared to services authorized,
we also have the potential
to really run into issues
associated with how
we're delivering services
warping how we're measuring
quality in services.
One of the other, and
more tricky, components
when it comes to measuring quality,
and this was a really heavy
emphasis in the discussion
of HCBS quality measures on the NQF panel
is how we look at quality
specifically within the context
of planning around service provision
as distinct from quality around
how service provision is delivered.
We generally know that within the context
of home and community-based services,
choice and control over
what you're getting
matters just as much as whether or not
and what particular form
of service provision
you're receiving.
So a growing number of quality measures
are looking at the degree to
which people are reporting
they have the right to
control what goes in their
service plan, the frequency
with which their services
can be reassessed, the
degree to which individuals
have easy access to service coordinators
and can clearly communicate
with them over time.
Some states have incorporated measures
like the percentage of
service coordinators
who have been trained in
self-directed services
and can offer that to an
individual as an option.
One of the challenges that comes up
when trying to measure
quality within the process
of determining how services are delivered,
is that often an emphasis on the process
can detract from an
emphasis on the outcomes.
So we have some states
that have chosen to measure
the percentage of individuals who choose
to self-direct their service as a metric
in quality outcomes in home
and community-based services.
Other states that have chosen to measure
the percentage of individuals
who end up in home
and community-based services,
or who end up in integrated employment.
And then we have other
states that have chosen
to measure the degree to which
those options are offered
as an alternative within the
service planning process.
And the challenge that
we really run into there
is if the emphasis is solely
on the planning process
and not on the broader
focus of what ends up being
delivered, we may have a situation
where a service coordinator
receives training
in self-direction or receives training
in integrated employment,
but that training does
not really translate
into concrete outcomes
in the field afterwards.
The National Core Indicators project
and other similar surveys
like the Council on Quality
Leaderships Personal
Outcomes Measure Survey
and others have long
looked at the question
of choice and control over people's lives
and this is something
that's highly relevant
within the context of the
home and community-based
settings rule and many states
are now asking themselves
within the context of their
settings transition plans,
every state must deliver
to the Federal government
and each state has but they're
periodically revising it,
a settings transition plan
indicating how they will comply
with the home and community-based
settings rule by 2019.
States are now asking
themselves how can I measure
compliance with
requirements of the settings
transition rule like facilitating choice
in who provides services
or optimizing autonomy
or allowing for privacy,
dignity and respect.
Often very broad-based
aspirational concepts
that in order to show
compliance with new Federal
requirements must be
operationalized at a very
practical level.
NCI and other quality
measures often look to survey
instruments around questions of quality
like, can you see your
friends when you want to?
Did you pick who you live with?
Did you pick where you live?
Did you get to pick who
your case manager is?
Or can you switch case
managers if you have a problem
with them?
Can you pick who your roommates are?
As a way of evaluating the
degree to which their state
or health plan or
potentially in the future
a Regional Center is delivering compliance
with the settings rule
or other program goals
in home and community-based services.
Self-direction is often
used as a metric for this
in part because it fits one
of the basic requirements
for a really good quality
measure and that's
significant variation across
the country in outcomes.
So this chart from the
National Resource Center
on Participant-Directed
Services shows the proportion
of people with disabilities
who are self-directing
as compared to the number
of individuals on SSI
within that given state.
One of the things you see is
that California, at the top,
is dramatically, dramatically
more likely to see
self-direction as an
outcome within the state
than the rest of the country.
So there's significant
variation, in fact about half
of people with disabilities
who self-direct live
in California, largely as a
function of the IHSS program
and so self-direction
often serves as a very
good indicator for evaluating home
and community-based services quality.
If we look at different
states self-directed programs
you have some that have
similar level of intensity,
California, Oregon and
Washington, New York,
Massachusetts, others,
Texas, others that are really
just getting stood up and that's something
that's helpful because a
quality measure doesn't
do very much for us if
it's a survey in which
consistently across every
state 95% of people say
they're happy with their services.
Again, this is a powerful
argument for coupling
multiple quality measures and looking,
prior to determining a
quality measure for use
in a particular purpose, that
there is variation in outcome.
Within the context of
both the settings rule
and broader program design goals
in home and community-based services,
states are beginning to look very closely
at community inclusion and
measures of community inclusion.
Usually what states
will do is they will tie
specific financial outcomes to metrics
of community inclusion,
and home and community-based services,
and in long-term services
and supports as a whole.
So many of the states
with the longest running
managed care systems for
long-term services and supports
will reward health plans
that increase the number of individuals
who transition from an ICF or nursing home
in a given year, from the expected
rate of transition based on past trends.
So if you're increasing the
speed at which individuals
leave institutional
settings then a health plan
is more likely to qualify for
additional bonus payments.
Often states will withhold
a certain percentage
of a capitated payment,
between three to five percent
is common, and basically
give multiple health plans
competing within a state
an opportunity to win
that pot of funds representing
three to five percent
of capitated payments within the state,
almost from the other
health plans in the event
that they show better outcomes than them.
The idea here is to
reflect for rebalancing
from institutional to
community-based settings,
an emphasis on competition
between health plans
as to who can accelerate that process.
What's relatively new and
one of the things looked at
by the NQF panel is measuring
quality within the context
of home and community-based
services themselves.
So New York, which has recently
embarked on a relatively
aggressive project of
promoting supported employment,
has incorporated within
their managed long-term
services and supports proposal
a indicator on the proportion
of individuals in sheltered workshops
who transitioned to integrated
community-based employment
and then the future
health plans in New York
may be in a position to see
additional reimbursement
in the event that they see more aggressive
integrated employment outcomes.
Hawaii, in which transportation
is a very significant issue,
decided to prioritize a
survey instrument tool
around individuals
receiving HCBS who reported
they had adequate
transportation when they wanted
to go somewhere.
New York, again, has emphasized
integrated employment.
So we're relatively new
in around quality measures
that are focusing on transitions
within one kind of HCBS
to another kind.
The next frontier there
is really to start to look
at how we measure HCBS service
quality and transitions
within residential placements.
States may soon be
adopting quality measures
that evaluate the percentage
of people who transition
from group homes to supported
living or shared living
settings in a very similar way
that we've seen in the past.
States evaluate the percentage of people
who are transitioning from
nursing homes and ICFs.
One of the other really important concepts
that has been emphasized
in an emerging way
in quality measurement
is the idea that services
are not just directed
towards the individual.
Particularly for people with
developmental disabilities,
the idea of having
access to natural support
and family support is absolutely critical.
So quality measures that
are looking at the degree
to which parents, family
members, other caregivers
can report that they are
able to maintain their health
in light of their caregiving obligations,
can report that they've been
receiving clear instructions
around paramedical
tasks that they may have
associated with the delivery
of services that a family
member may be expected to take on.
Obviously we want a quality
measure that's going to be
telling us if a family
member is expected to perform
substantial medical tasks
but isn't being given
any kind of instruction or
support as to how to do that.
As well as other measures
that are looking at the idea
that the health of the family relationship
is an important component in the quality
of service provision.
I want to emphasize why this matters,
especially as we start to see the shift
towards managed care.
Typically, and there's variation
and certainly California
is one of the significant
sources of the variation here
as a state that is generally
not put its developmental
disability services and managed care,
but in most of the country
a managed care contract
lasts between three to five years.
So a state will contract
with a health plan,
usually one of the large
national health plans,
sometimes local nonprofits,
and they will say you have control over,
you have responsibility
over this population
with some shifts in
open enrollment periods,
between competing health
plans over the next
three to five years, and if
you are that health plan,
one of the things you very quickly realize
is that families who have a commitment
to supporting their
relative with a disability
can probably hold on, in a lot of cases,
for three to five years,
even with a relatively poor
quality of service provision.
So if all you're counting
on for a health plan
to be incentivized to
deliver high-quality services
is the fear that someone's
going to end up in an ICF
or more expensive placement in
the event that those services
are not delivered, often times
health plans will operate
under the assumption that's six years out.
That's seven or ten or fifteen years out,
we don't need to concern
ourselves with that.
So one of the purposes of
measuring dimensions of quality,
which maybe down the line
are going to correlate
to dimensions of cost,
is so that you can say,
health plan you are
financially on the hook
for meeting these
measures that will tell us
if the families who are
providing unpaid supports
to people with disabilities
are barely holding on,
even if that family is
going to end up holding on
past the term of your contract.
And that's a very consistent
theme in other metrics as well.
We generally see that supported employment
is more cost-effective
to payers than sheltered
workshop services over a
long enough time frame.
So health plans are not held
accountable for delivering
integrated employment outcomes within
that three to five year time frame
with which they have contracts,
they may say, alright,
this is an area of our OI
that's realized seven to ten years out,
we don't have to focus on that.
So again, one of the overall
goals in caregiver support,
in integrated employment
and in other areas,
is to make sure that
health plans and others
who have responsibility
often on a short-term basis
in evaluating and delivering services
to people with disabilities
are responsible
and have a financial
incentive to promote quality
even if the consequences
aren't going to come
for years later.
We're short on time so I'm
gonna jump forward a little bit.
We have other measures that are available
in your program books around workforce,
human and legal rights, equity
and holistic health and functioning.
I do want to highlight a couple of things
within this context:
Equity is an area in
which quality measurement
is often still relatively new.
States have very different
ideas or different priorities
around where their
equity considerations are
in home and community-based services.
If you are a very diverse state,
or to talk in the California context,
a very diverse Regional
Center, you may have particular
priorities around equity
in the delivery and outcome
of services across linguistic
and racial and ethnic minorities.
Many of you are very familiar
with the racial disparities
in the California Regional Center systems
delivery of purchase of service funds,
and that's a significant
area in which equity
is being measured and
hopefully in the future
that will lead to more equitable outcomes.
There's also been a focus
on how we can look at health
within the context of how health
intersects with long-term
services and supports.
Because quality measures
have mostly come about
when states have adopted
managed care systems,
and most state-managed
care systems in the 1990's
and early aughts emphasize
non-disabled adults and children,
usually quality measures
focus when they looked
at medical outcomes,
just on medical outcomes
in the context of primary
and specialty doctors care,
hospital services and other
traditional acute care outcomes.
One of the things that's
being looked at now
is how we can start to focus
on outcomes that specifically
look at individuals who are receiving home
and community-based
services and their special
healthcare needs.
So I want to touch on
a couple of just closing principles
that I think are important for considering
what quality measures may be doing for us
over the course of the
next five to ten years.
One of the most important
things that quality measures do,
in addition to holding health
plans, service providers,
Regional centers accountable,
is they give very clear
instructions to the field
about where innovation
should be prioritized.
I mentioned that my new rule,
I manage a project called MySupport,
which is an online provider directory
that makes it easy for
people with disabilities
to find workers that share their values,
answering match questions
around personality, values,
support needs and other components,
to make it easy for folks to find workers,
one of the reasons we
entered into the process
of developing the MySupport
platform is it had become
very clear that states and
people with disabilities
advocating to states about
what kinds of qualities
should be promoted in
the future were heavily
emphasizing self-direction as an outcome
that should be encouraged.
In California, that's
taken the role of the
"may come swiftly and
within our days" upcoming
self-determination program.
In other states that's taken
the role of health plans
being required to increase the percentage
of individuals with
disabilities and seniors
who are self-directing their own services
on a year-on-year basis.
But one of the things
we say when we embark
on quality measurement
is we want our system
to move in this particular
direction and in doing so,
we tell technology
providers, service providers,
advocates and other stake holders,
this can be an area of
common focus and common cause
over the course of the coming years.
In the future, one of the biggest areas
in which quality measurement
has not yet focused
but we're starting to
see an emphasis around,
is quality measurement
at the provider level.
There's a long track record
of using quality measures
to hold a health plan
or a state accountable
for outcomes across the
broad scope of services,
the broad scope of
providers within a system.
What we've started to
see is the introduction
of reimbursement strategies
to particular providers
that reward them for
delivering better outcomes.
One of the biggest areas
this has been happening
is in employment service provision.
A number of states have
adopted employment service
provision reimbursement models
where a service provider
is no longer reimbursed
solely for the number of hours
of job coaching they provide
but instead it can be
reimbursed for the number of hours
the people they are
supporting are working.
That's a very significant shift.
It means that service
providers don't realize a loss
if they're doing better at
encouraging natural supports.
Starting to fade out their roll over time.
We're beginning to think
about how we can apply that
to residential service provision as well
as we look to encourage the
possibility for residential
service providers to help
facilitate natural supports
and community relationships
in a way that will mean that
that provider's rewarded
for what we want to see:
people getting support,
people getting help
from their broader
community instead of solely
through paid service provision.
We've also started to see
opportunities for providers
to take on some degree of
risk within the service
provision system.
At the Federal level, and
there's some very deep concerns
that the implementation of
this may not keep to our values
around community inclusion,
there's now a proposal
to introduce the PACE model
in which a service provider
becomes fully responsible
for the broad scope
of somebody's LTSS and medical services
for non-elderly people with disabilities.
But the overall concept here is,
we've for a long time been
emphasizing measuring quality
in how we hold our states accountable
and how we hold our
health plans accountable
and in the future quality
measurement can be a tool
we use to go to providers and say,
"We expect you to deliver
the kinds of self-determined,
"included lives that we
want for our community.
"We're going to make sure
that in the ways we pay you,
"and in the ways we compensate you,
"you have the opportunity
to benefit from that."
I'm going to stop here
and hopefully we've left
enough time for the panel.
Thank you all very much for your time.
(applause)